assalamualaikum brothers and sisters I
got some amazing news for you and I'm
really surprised that the mainstream
media hasn't picked this up let me tell
you first of all the physical side
before we do this the spiritual side
brothers and sisters we've all had loved
ones that passed away a mother a father
a brother sister a close family member
for one of the mercies of our Dean is
that with the right intention we can go
ahead and continue to do good deeds on
our loved ones behalf and what greater
of a continuous Good Deeds
than investing on their behalf in the
dean Center a Masjid and nagada Center
that will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you let's meet a former pastor by
the name of
um
converted to Islam in his own church get
this
in the church they were supporting what
I was saying they were also say it
everybody repeat after me now this is a
South African priest of 15 years leader
of his congregation from the Corinthian
Church of South Africa what's up
Christopher 15 years now leader of the
communication the quotient Church of
South Africa there's got about 100 000
followers I want you to imagine this
you're going to Sunday service and you
got the priest
your priest the leader of the
congregation giving you shahada saying
the shahada the Declaration of faith
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator of the heavens and
earth
he's saying this to his congregation he
is actually accepting himself Islam and
now also his congregation is also coming
to Islam subhanallah everybody repeat
after me
[Music]
except Allah
I mean I've been doing this a long time
I've seen monks priests I mean you got
left wing right wing conservatives you
name it
is someone sincere and they're seeking
to know the purpose of life and they
look in Islam they're going to be doing
the same thing but to see such a large
following in his own church and three
months ago I met
in the church they were supporting what
I was saying they were also say it those
thousand voices sing one
Allah
[Music]
a witness I bear witness I'm the worthy
of worship there's none worthy of
worship except Allah accept Allah and
Muhammad is his final messenger he's the
final messenger later it's said that
this church it actually turned into a
Masjid this is a prophecy that is being
fulfilled this is a right in front of
your eyes right in front of our eyes
this is a truly amazing this is just
another sign that God Almighty Allah is
putting out there for you to see for the
world to see that Islam is definitely
the way of life from the creator of the
heavens and earth now I'm really
surprised that there aren't many other
news sources covering this we've had
some Muslims cover this but we don't
have this would be great for some of the
mainstream media to go ahead and cover
such Amazing Stories like this even
local media I mean some news hopefully
they'll watch the show that we do right
now on this is news update amazing news
update might I say and hopefully they'll
pick up on this story and this is this
is something amazing to report on ends
up getting invited by the Saudi
government now to come and do Hajj then
he explains a little bit of what
happened
he came again and again and the last
time this voice became aggressive now
tell your man then I went it was a
congregation I said now I'm going
towards these people I'm going to tell
them told them
you know how we how Allah made it easy
they just accept it
all of them then when the next meeting
came on the next congregation
everyone was wearing it quite curtas and
all those they accepted they accepted
and we know dreams can come in different
types you can have dreams Come
inspiration that comes from the Creator
from God Almighty you can have dreams
from the ramblings of your mind you can
also have dreams from the devil but if
you have a good dream and now it leads
you to look into Islam and then you look
into Islam you say man this just makes
sense worship one God worship the
Creator not the creation be morally
upright and all the time everything just
goes with your human nature goes it's
the natural way then you can also have a
dream and that dream now how do you know
it's from the devil because it goes
opposite to what God Almighty wants you
to do now you get a dream and in the
Dream It's uh it's calling you to
identify as something that God Almighty
didn't create you to be as a Lamppost as
an animal as as opposite of the body
part that you were created with that's a
problem now now that goes against now
you can say this is some this would be a
dream of the devil this will be from the
Satanic forces you get the difference
okay but when you have a dream that's
now something in line and then the
person goes it's a sign and then you go
investigate and you look at Islam and
you look at the teachings you're like
man this just makes sense it's the pure
monotheism that I've been invited to
it's the way of Jesus Moses Abraham and
all the other Messengers last
that's all
it's a there's a chain that was there
from the beginning it's not different
religions anyways you look at it and it
just makes sense it's nothing strange
nothing esoteric no strange
superstitions it makes good old common
sense and now you share this with your
congregation they accept now he ends up
getting invited to Hajj he goes to the
Hajj and he's kind of going over this
and explaining some of his experience
who he is and what happened and whatnot
I mean this is just truly mind-blowing
it's amazing this is prophesized in in
Islam in the Quran this is something
that Prophet Muhammad also foretold that
this would be happening alhamdulillah
Muslim Brothers coming I said I've been
waiting for you
I've been waiting for you I had a dream
[Music]
you'll come here
please be upon Him Muhammad
when we went up here he was alone I will
follow the footsteps
and I believe by following these
footsteps Millions
of my people in South Africa would
follow these footsteps
you see the light
now before we conclude I want to also
introduce you to another priest
who was on his way he was on a mission
sent on a mission by an Archbishop and
on his way he ends up getting stranded
so he goes to a church and ends up in a
mosque and now he's relaying this story
this is a very interesting story also by
another priest in his congregation
talking about the Brotherhood and the
love and his wonderful experience
sleeping in a Masjid a mosque it's
simple you go anywhere they tell you
Muslim Muslim
anywhere you go to they will tell you a
Muslim is the brother of a Muslim
I have shared with you here a terrible
thing I hate sharing it
I was sent by the Archbishop somewhere
and I got stranded on the way
I went to a church
to go and tell them that they should I
want to spend the night there
I heard the pastor and the wife arguing
inside
I told them I said look I will not sleep
in your house I want to sleep in the
church
sir they didn't allow me
I left that place and walked to a mosque
I the only thing I said is assalamu
alaikum
and he looked at me he said
he said laugh here I said Bismillah
he said I should I should sit Bismillah
so he told me he was he was eating his
garage
sir we finished she said
I slept in the mosque
in the morning
[Music]
before the early morning prayers before
he knows that it is not I only say
salaam alaikum
I quickly step out sir is it with that
kind of Christianity are you thinking we
can we can dismantle that Force
our self-centered
self-seeking
self-glorifying Christianity
a Christianity that only thinks about
himself
all right so there you have it you had a
South African priest of 15 years takes
shahada the Declaration of Faith
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one Creator the creator of the
heavens and the Earth Allah and Muhammad
is his messenger this would
automatically include all the preceding
messages that came Jesus Moses Abraham
Noah you name it David Solomon Ishmael
all these were Messengers that came with
this exact same message worship one and
only one God don't worship nothing in
creation but the one God nothing else
but him alone that's it and obey the
messenger that was sent at your time at
Jesus time he was the messenger so you
would say
Isa which was his name rasulullah Jesus
is the messenger at Moses time Moses the
messenger and this time Muhammad is a
messenger he's saying that in front of
his whole congregation they accept Islam
and they're going by this book now the
Quran
this is the Quran and the teachings of
the Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon them and the authentic prophetic
statements which we had the Hadith I
like to gift this to you you can go to
thedene show.com to see what led this
man what teachings is he living by now
this is all Illustrated in this book
I'll get it to you for free
I believe this is uh we'll can do it for
United States and Canada and also if you
have any questions don't be shy
telemedi sent you call the number say
look I was watching The Dean Sean I had
this question
you got some misconception in your head
you got some ideas about Islam and
you're like okay let me before I go
ahead and take the next step I need
these things cleared up go ahead tell
them I sent you
1-800-662 Islam
operators are standing by to go ahead
and answer your questions even help
facilitate if you want to visit a Masjid
a mosque if you want to take your
shahada
because you're thinking deeply you're
reflecting what's the purpose of life
why am I here why have I been created
like every human being should be
thinking and contemplating because death
is a reality and when it comes you can't
go back and retake the test you're being
tested we're being tested now and this
is another sign like you've seen with
these priests and pastors and whole
congregations coming to this truth
because it fits like a glove and I
guarantee you if you can dig this main
message worshiping the Creator not his
creation everything else God willing
will fall in place but do your homework
I need you to do your homework and ass
just like if you need directions in life
if you need to go somewhere and you need
and you were stranded and you you needed
to know which way is east or west and
you would ask if you needed some money
if you were hungry imagine you hadn't
eaten for days
and you're starving you'd be begging for
food what about begging for guidance
it's more important than any of these
things begging for guidance to really
knowing what you're doing in this life
who do you ask it from from the creator
of Life say Guide Me Guide Me Guide Me
enough said peace be with you assalamu
alaikum we've been told yeah they're out
to kill us all assalamualaikum brothers
and sisters we went to the streets to
ask Americans about Islam here's what
they said do you know anything about
Islam No do you know anything about
Islam No sadly do you know anything
about Islam uh not really do you know
anything about Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that they're
out to kill us all
that's what you've been told that
Muslims are out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're going to have four
wives brothers and sisters as you can
see there are so many Americans who
don't know about Islam we need your help
to change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign